[موسيقى]
موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله اجرام مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكيه جيك سوليفان مباحثات في اسرائيل
والاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله تمهيدا
لزياره وزير الخارجيه
وقال البيت الابيض والناس هوليفان شدد
خلال المباحثات على دعم حلل دولتين وحدران
من تاجيج التوتر نتيجه الخطوات الاحاديه
من جهته قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو تحركات الفلسطينيين على
صحه الدوليه هجوم على اسرائيل يستدعي الرد
وقالت رئاسه الفلسطينيه ان الرئيس محمود
عباس طالب خلال لقائه سلفا الاداره
الامريكيه بالتدخل فورا لوضع حد للتصعيد
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
كشفت صحيفه بوليتيكو الامريكيه في تقرير
لها عن وجود التباين وتردد داخل حلف
الناتو الذي يجتمع وزراء دفاعه اليوم في
رانشتاين بالمانيا بشان زياده الانفاق
الدفاعي وانقلت بوليتكو عن دبلوماسي
الاوروبي قوله ان بعض الدول الاوروبيه غير
مستعده لرفع الانفاق الدفاعي باكثر من
اثنين في المئه
من جهته قل الرئيس الامريكي
تتوقعوا من اجتماع رمشتاين حزمه قويه من
الدعم العسكري الامريكي وجدد انتقاده
المانيا على ما سماه ترددها في الاذن بام
دادي بلاده بدبابه اليو بارك
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه تقديمها دفعه
جديده من المساعدات الامنيه الاوكرانيا
بقيمه مليارين ونصف الملياردو دولار تتضمن
الشحنه ثمانيه منظومات للدفاع الجوي من
طراز افنجر ومئات العربات المدرعه وتسعين
ناقله سترايكر مصفحه اضافه الى ذخائر
لمنظمات الصواريخ من طراز هايمارس
الكريم
رفع مستوى الزراعي الى درجه لا تبشره
بالخير اذا الامن يا ربي
نقلت صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن مسؤولين
امريكيين ومصادر مطلعه قولهم انه
ويليامبرز مديره وكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه اجرى زياره سريه
لاوكرانيا نهايه الاسبوع الماضي ليطلع
الرئيس لينسيكي على توقعاته بخطط روسيا
العسكريه في الاسابيع والاشهر المقبله
هاجمت حركه الشباب قاعده عسكريه القوات
الصوماليه بمدينه
الصوماليه قد سيطرت عليها الاثنين الماضي
بعد انسحاب مقاتلي الحركه كامله
انت هذا الموجز لما كنتم طلب توقتكم بكل
خير
[موسيقى]